spring and maurice jones-drew NFL
Network analyst a former NFL running
back he was the radio analyst for
yesterday's Rams Saints game mojo good
to have you on again how are you I'm
doing okay
let me ask you the the poll question
here the best triplet combination in the
NFL if I gave you Brees chimera and
Thomas mahomes hunt and Hill golf early
cooks Rivers Gordon Allen Roethlisberger
Connor or Antonio Brown that's tough you
know after last night watching the
Saints it's hard to say it's hard to go
against the Saints and what they were
able to do at home I think all those are
great combinations the only problem with
the Rams one is you have to pick one of
the three wide receivers and that's what
makes them special is that they have
three guys but I would I would go Brees
chimera and Michael comas after seeing
that last night who scores more points
this year Todd Gurley or the Buffalo
Bills Todd Gurley we know what Nathan
Peterman is and so in this situation
you're not giving yourselves a chance
like you have to sometimes in business
we have to do things that we don't want
to that's better for the program we
always hear people say you know this is
better for the team and we're gonna
actually take a baker that is better for
the team or we're gonna ask you we're
going to cut you because it's better for
the team well you may need a sign color
Kaepernick because it's better for the
team
Nathan Peterman isn't answered Erik
Anderson came and gave it his best try
he's not the answer and while you're
young quarterback is hurt and doesn't
have a elbow you need to give your guys
hope and opportunity that they can be
confident to go into a game and win and
after seeing you know watching some
highlights and catching up some of the
game last night
cuz I was I was and I was just like wow
41 to 9 there wasn't a lot of hope out
there as far as the game that you saw
though with the Rams in st. she learned
more about the Saints of the Rams in
that game last night I think you learned
a lot about both for me it was the Rams
had an opportunities early in there
early in the first half when they got a
turnover to go and take that game over
anytime you're at home and you're in a
environment like the dome you have to be
able to go in score points you have to
be able to put yourself in position to
be to really take the crowd out of it
now I was high up calling the game and
the crowd noise you can still hear it
but on the field I heard it was
deafening and so when you got that
fumble from Mark Ingram
it was probably is really imperative to
go in there and get at least three and
you came out with zero there and I was
something that Coach debate talked about
just being better in those situations
and then you know you have to score when
you play the Saints we all know this you
have to score then when I learned it and
that's when I wasn't one of the Rams
what I learned about the Saints their
defense is very opportunistic they find
ways to try to get the ball out granted
the Rams went up and down the field on
them but they had you know they had to
turn over that they were able to to
gather in this score right away off of
right before half which put them out to
that 30 or 514 lead and so I really
thought you had two really good teams
playing against each other whose
defenses weren't really uh executing at
a high level but the offenses were
flying well and that that's how you have
to win they were finding ways to try to
win games
yeah the Rams defense and you know we've
seen this before where teams try to
build a super super defense you bring in
parts and then you try to make it work
and the secondary is a big concern there
I know if you're scoring 35 points
you're you're gonna win most games in
the NFL but do you see that as a bigger
issue as we get closer to the playoffs
for the Rams that's secondary no not
really
I think going out it was definitely a
problem because normally when when the
keyed person was in there the earlier
this year he covered the the top
receiver most majority of the time they
really didn't switch sides unless they
had to and so when he was in he would
cover I want to say he was covering
Keenan Allen when they were playing the
Chargers and they put Marcus Peters on
Mike Williams and so in those situations
like they when you have a guy like a key
who's you know season has played some of
these guys has been around he can you
know he could use some analogies game
throughout his career to play some of
these different number one wide
receivers well Marcus Peters he
used to being a gambler a guy who plays
off coverage who does different things
and you're asking to do something
completely different here so he's gonna
have mistakes and he he owned up to it
after the game when he was being
interviewed about you know it's on me
it's not anyone else I know I'm better
than this I have to play better than
this and as and as an organization as a
team they just have to figure out ways
to put their guy you know put him in
this position if he is covering these
number-one guys to make sure that he's
comfortable today he's Maurice
jones-drew the NFL Network analyst
former NFL running back any problems
with Michael Thomas celebration with the
cell phone not at all why we have these
rules to celebrate why would there be a
problem I actually you know shoutout to
Joe horn you know III think I was a I
was a young kid when he did that was
that 98 did he do that in 98 I thought
it was like 2003 when I was in high
school did yes sir I was I was still
young a young lad trying to find my way
around this world it really inspired me
to celebrate when I saw that but I think
you're I mean listen II know first when
I was a great play a ballsy throw by
Drew Brees with the game on the line
you're gonna throw a go route and I mean
those those type of things and I know
there's a lot of players I talked about
it about him being the you know Mike
Tyson looking for the knockout punch all
the time and that's a great mindset but
to throw that type of ball in that
situation that takes a lot of guts from
everybody and so he ran actually they
ran that play before I want to say a
third down right before that and he
threw it to the other side and gave the
Rams they got it they got out and I
guarantee you Michael Thompson's like I
had I had Marcus Peters 101 throw the go
ball to me so they came back to it and
they did I mean did a phenomenal job
executing and when you do that you get a
chance for that's what you get to do you
won the game yeah yeah I think the
timing of it though it was still a tight
game and and you'd blown an 18 point
lead so I like the celebrations though
mojo I do I just
in that situation I just thought you
know what
you're playing against the Rams it's it
and maybe that maybe this is where he
gets national attention and people
realize just how great he is I you know
maybe it's sad that he needed that to
get national attention because he is an
elite yeah he's one of the top five
receivers in the game I think so you
know maybe maybe oh yeah I mean he's
he's a fun player I also wanted to ask
you a couple more things running backs
don't you know hurdling now like why is
this become a new trend here where these
guys are trying to leapfrog defenders
you got to protect your legs I was lucky
and fortunate enough that I was so short
that guys it was it was they had to go
lower than they thought but for some of
these tall guys you you have to protect
your knees and your legs that's how guys
are tackling you so the way to do it is
to jump now I mean Alvin camara did it
in the Rams Saints game I Todd Gurley
has done in multiple times I want to say
to James Conner do it is well I mean
guys mechanical because yeah McCaffrey
he's honest he's a little bit taller
than me too I wouldn't say he's too much
taller than that that he may be having
like some stuff in his shoes but when
you're when you're a dynamic running
back and you're going against safeties
and corners all they try to do is take
your legs out and so for me my deal was
trying to figure out how to either shake
them or lower my shoulder on kinda they
couldn't get as low as I could but the
other thing was to make sure that I that
you protect your knees because that's
sure that's your resume right if you if
you look at any running back of you if
your knees go down if your knees get
hurt or you get you go down immediately
teams and coaches are going to say
you're worn out and you're you're over
and done with so you got to make sure
you protect your money and that leads us
to lay beyond bail last time you Ron you
were very vocal and had great opinions
about you you thought lay beyond bail
was doing the right thing I you know
you're betting on yourself
he's lost this bet you know because
James Conner is the bet because he's not
getting paid and James Conner has you
know they don't miss him James Conner is
having a better year than lay beyond
Bell had last year the first of all this
was never about James Conner having a
better year than Lady I'm bill that this
was never the situation that the whole
reason he's not there is to preserve his
body
Steelers the Steelers were betting on
Connor but it's not about that I think
that's where everything is mrs. cute it
wasn't this has never been about James
Connor of the Steelers this is about lay
beyond preserving his body because if
you go out how many touches have James
Conner has Jane Connor had and over the
throughout the course of the season can
we I know you have researchers there can
they look it up catches and carries I
think he's close to two or three hundred
or two hundred right now and this
halfway through the year he's got a
hundred and 0 151 carries and he's got
30 38 catches that's 100 that's a 180 so
you times that by 2 that's 360 right 360
touches where you're getting hit on
every one of those ok that's that's what
that's what lay beyond Bell was saying
like I'm not going to let you lie here
and put 400 carries on me 400 touches on
me again and so this was never this has
never been an argument like where I
think we we see this a lot where it's
like the players are fighting for money
lady I was not fighting for money he's
fighting for to preserve his body and so
that's why he said I'm not going to show
up and I wrote an article for nfl.com
never much to go out and look at it was
in week one about what I felt lay beyond
should do in this situation because this
is not an argument over over cash this
is an argument over preserving his body
and so we all see it as James Connors
doing well lady I wasn't texting James
Connor every week telling him great job
because this had nothing to do with him
well then why he had to do with amount
right why would lay beyond bell come
back at all then well he has to come
back to get their credited season he has
to come back to get their credited
season - then get transition tagged now
once you get transitions you can go out
there negotiate with anything you want
to and get a deal done and then
Pittsburgh has to match it now with the
width the way James Connor is playing
right because it's a win-win for
everybody with the way James Connor is
playing do you think Pittsburgh will
match a 40 million dollar deal for lady
on bail no okay there was a lady on then
guess what he wants get to play for a
team and then guess it what his friend
did James Conner who's been playing well
very both sides win it's good to go you
know both sides can win in this
situation but Jesus things
teams are gonna they want Le'Veon Bell
that a guy who doesn't a guy who does it
one so what happens in the last year of
your contract it's not that he doesn't
want to play he wants to play but he had
to make a business decision to preserve
his box okay but then I get to the last
year of his deal with the next team mojo
and then he's going to pull the same
thing not really I think if you use that
argument the slippery slope argument and
I think that's a horrible argument I
think if he's 27 now you signed him to a
deal he knows my Chinese 30 to 31 but he
has to go out there and show that he can
run at that age very simple I mean that
that it has nothing to do with the I
remember at running backs ages playing
to all these different things yeah
and so I that's all it is this is
literally he's in his prime of his
career and I'm gonna tell you why teams
are going to sign them because when you
hear about Todd Gurley you talk about
the top running backs everyone says yeah
but lady on is not playing which means
what that you still have that thought in
your mind that lay beyond is still one
of the top backs and Lee when he's on
the field so as the next thing you get
lay beyond to come in okay after after
he know he's gonna play when he comes in
the camp went out before this deadline
when he comes to the team for a deadline
he's gonna play some and when he plays
some you're gonna see if he's still the
same old but am I allowed to load him up
mojo am I allowed to load him up with
touches here or is he gonna go hey you
got to do whatever you want once you get
in the building
but six weeks of carries versus 16 weeks
of carries I think teams would
appreciate that a little bit more right
or right or wrong uh we will disagree on
it you you see it - oh I gotta come I
gotta come on the show I see it from I
say from a player's perspective not a
team's perspective I understand a team
side I understand the team side I
understand lay beyond bells perspective
here honor absolutely I get where he
would do it it's you know I liken it to
CC Sabathia in his last year in
Milwaukee it felt like they pitched him
every other day because they knew they
weren't gonna resign him and then he
goes to the Yankees I under
stand that exactly yeah absolutely I get
it I just think lady on Bell borough how
is he gonna get that money back that
he's lost eight million dollars you know
what in an eight million dollar sounds a
lot to a lot of people who don't make
that type of money which is fine he
can't get that money back what he can do
is preserve his body to make the forty
million dollars so would you ever
sacrifice eight million make four you're
going to make forty million yes Dan if
he got four hundred touches three years
back to back to back do you think
someone that some other team is going to
pay him forty million dollars after
having twelve hundred carries in three
years it depends on how productive he is
well I think teams will come in and say
well you know he's had this many carries
there's many times from the business
side and that and that's an issue so I
didn't fit sup to me and you know I
think I personally feel and I might have
to answer your question about Mike
Thomas too laughter this before we go I
personally feel that lady I made a
decision he stuck with that decision
where most players don't stick with it I
was a player they didn't stick with that
decision um and so he's written this
thing out to the point where he's given
himself the best chance to maximize his
earning potential in the future that's
all you can hone this no I got it
suppose a hundred percent injuries for
it so you have to be able to try to
maximize your potential he's done that
so we can't everyone keeps saying like
James Connor has done this and granite
I'm going to say this with all respect
to James Connor and everything that he's
done he's done a phenomenal job but when
teams will come in to Pittsburgh they
don't say we're trying to stop James
Connor like they do lady on bill and
that's why a B and Big Ben were having
such problems early in the year that's
why a B was so upset because when lady
on bills on the field a B's to the
defenses the second guy and so now a B
here now the first guy so they're seeing
coverage tilted towards him until the
team started now James Carter starting
to get going so things like okay we have
to now consider this this this young man
who's playing really well as a viable
threat and that's all it is and so teams
are starting to consider James Connor
now is a viable threat but early in the
year it was all about stopping a B
big bin and that's why though that team
was struggling very simple now I have to
answer your Mike Thomas celebration
question what high school did you go to
Mason High School
it was arrival everybody know but you
had one rival you had a team that you
always played in the same city or
something you know yeah but I but I it
was Springboro but I own Springboro so
not really a rival so listen the Saints
have done a great job of really playing
well over the last couple years the Rams
are coming up and actually I heard a
coach Payton say it he was like you know
everyone tell us about this young
offensive coordinator and this and that
and that in this and all he's all
they're doing is starting a new rivalry
and when you in order to start a rival
you have to disrespect someone to the
point where they fill it personally mojo
I would have no problem if there was a
minute left in that game and he did it
there was over three minutes left you
had blown an 18 point lead and the Rams
offense is great I just I didn't like
the timing of it I didn't mind the the
tribute to Joe horn so I want to make
sure you I didn't like the timing of it
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
bring this show to Los Angeles next week
just so you'll stop by the studio all
right we're we're uh we're going to LA
next next week to see beau Joe we're
gonna do shows out there in Los Angeles
done deal Frenchy start booking people
we're going out there and I'm gonna go
out there to do a show because Maurice
Jones behind the case all right there
you go that's how it's done mojo you
know when you're the man you can do
those everything I just hope my whole
holy aspirations to get to where you are
so that I can just tell people where
we're gonna go cuz I'll be like hey
we're gonna go to New York this week
yeah but you gonna go to meet you
you know what you can't get two six
three I mean that's yes yeah cuz your
father your five seven and I'm six-three
so you'll never get to where I am I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
think I think I have opportunity I'll
stretch my bones
weird out all right well I'm bringing
I'm gonna see you next week all right
I'll be okay all right I can't go
anywhere all right it's on it's on like
Donkey Kong that's uh Maurice Jones
through we're going to LA for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]